There are sunsets on other planets, even
more spectacular than the ones on earth.
What if we could see not just one,
but two sons falling
below the Earth's horizon?
What our planet get much warmer
with two stars heating it up.
Would we ever experience nighttime again?
It could.
Our binary star system
be able to sustain life.
This is what if, and here's what
would happen if we had two sons.
Not all star systems form
around a single star.
Some scientists even suggest that
our son once had a star companion,
a long lost wharf star called Nemesis.
It broke free of the sun's gravity and
melted into the milky way billions of
years ago.
Our search for earth size
planets throughout the galaxy
showed us that not only
our most our systems binary,
but they also have habitable
zones and planets within them.
It looks like the earth could sustain
life with two sons instead of just one,
but only under certain conditions.
In a binary star system.
Earth's fate would depend on many factors
from the masses of the stars to their
position relative to Earth,
and each other.
Chances are high that Earth's orbit
would be very unstable if one of the sons
was bigger and brighter and had a much
stronger gravitational impact on us.
That son could pull the
planet towards itself.
We get pretty crispy before
disappearing and it's solar flares.
On the other hand, if neither stars,
gravitational pull was strong enough,
the earth would fly out into space,
would become one of those rogue planets
that traveled the universe all alone
with no star system to call home.
Let's assume that the Earth's
orbit would be stable.
This would be possible if the earth
orbit had just one of the sons,
but that's no good for complex life
on the planet because at some point,
the stars would face both sides
of the planet at the same time.
Not only would that take away our nights,
but it would also bring double doses
of UV radiation and solar winds.
No sunscreen could prevent you
from getting toasted by two sons.
The Earth's orbit could be stable. If
the planet rotated around the two stars,
the stars would have to be close together
and the Earth's orbit would be further
away.
Just how far away most likely beyond
the habitable zone where the heat of the
sons wouldn't be enough to keep
our water in a liquid state.
The planet would turn into a frozen
lifeless rock feeling hopeless yet?
Well,
we have some good news for you.
The best case scenario for our planet
would be if we replaced our son with two
closely matched stars.
Each half is bright as the sun.
This would keep our planet warm enough
to sustain life because of the total
gravity of the two
stars would be stronger.
It would take the earth 280 days instead
of 365 to make a whole circle around
them.
The distance between the stars would have
to be less than 15 million kilometers
apart that the orbits of all the other
planets in our system would be stable.
Even Mercury's,
but let's play safe and assume the
distance between the stars was about 5
million kilometers in that scenario.
The two stars would orbit each other
once every 10 days, every five days.
One Star would pass in front of another
from Earth that would look like a solar
eclipse,
but instead of our moon blocking the sun,
it would be one star blocking another,
and instead of seven and a half minutes,
that eclipse would last for about
five hours. Under those conditions,
the earth could be just
fine orbiting two sons.
The only question is whether the earth
would have formed in a binary star system
in the first place.
As far as we know,
the smallest planets circling two sons
is a gas giant, much bigger than earth.
Maybe there is a small rocky planet like
earth orbiting two sons somewhere in
the universe.
We just haven't found it yet.
It might even sustain life intelligent
enough to send a signal to our planet,
but that's a topic for another.
What if.